Speaker 1: All right, let's get to a couple of
wacky things in different ways, this memo has now
leaked. This is a memo from Donald Trump's lawyer
with a plan, a six point plan for how they wanted
to overturn the results of the 2012 election.
This memo is remarkable, but for more than one
reason. It's remarkable because of the audacity
of thinking to do this. It's also remarkable
because it makes clear to me that they know this
is all B.S. They know Trump didn't actually win.
And it's also remarkable because I wonder,
had someone even more absurd than Mike Pence
been president, a vice president at the time? Is
there a chance not that it would have actually
kept Trump in office, but that it might have led
to even more chaos if the vice president had been
willing to at least try some of this stuff?
So the International Business Times reporting
leaked memo shows how Trump's lawyer wanted Pence
to overturn elections. The leaked memo outlined
six steps Pence could take to declare Trump the
winner of the election. The memo included plans
to overthrow the Electoral College votes from
seven states. Pence argued the Constitution did
not give him power to overturn the results. This
is all outlined in the book Peril, which explains
that conservative lawyer John Eastman allegedly
sent a two page memo outlining these steps.
At the end, he announces that because of
the ongoing disputes in the seven states,
there are no electors that can be deemed validly
appointed in those states, meaning the total
number of electors appointed is for 50. For a
majority of those appointed would be 228 and
Trump would have to 32 of them. Now we're going to
look at the six point plan in detail in a moment.
Some of these details are wild, which includes
that the proposal was first given to Pence on
January four, two days before the riot, when
Trump attempted to convince the then president,
the then vice president, that he had the authority
to overturn it. You really need to listen to John.
He's a respected constitutional scholar. Hear him
out, Trump told Pence. However, Pence refused to
intervene, saying he doesn't have that authority.
And then this is maybe the craziest detail.
On January six hours before the riot, Pence told
Trump, Constitution doesn't let me do it. And that
led Trump to hold their friendship hostage. No,
no, no, Trump shouted. You don't understand, Mike.
You can do this. I don't want to be your friend
anymore if you don't do this. So let's look at the
six point plan. OK, step one pence presiding over
the joint session or Senate Pro Tem Grassley. If
Pence recuses begins to open and count ballots,
starting with Alabama, without conceding that
the procedure specified by the Electoral Count
Act of going through the states alphabetically
is required. When he gets to Arizona, he announces
he has multiple slates of electors and so is going
to defer decision until on that until finishing
the other states. This would be the first break
with the procedure set out in the act. So this is
an idea we talked about before. They were talking
about you just send different electors, send
send Republican electors. Step three at the end,
he announces that because of the ongoing disputes
in seven states, there are no electors that can
be deemed validly appointed in those states. That
means the total number of electors appointed. The
language of the Twelfth Amendment is four fifty
for this. Reading of the Twelfth Amendment has
also been advanced by Harvard law professor
Laurence Tribe. A majority of the electors
appointed would therefore be two twenty eight.
If you reduce the number of appointed electors,
you reduce what it counts as 50 percent plus one.
There are at this point to thirty two for Trump
to twenty two for Biden. Pence gavels President
Trump as reelected howls, of course, from the
Democrats, who now claim contrary to tribes prior
position, that 270 is required. So Penn says fine.
Pursuant to the 12th Amendment, no candidate has
achieved the necessary majority. That sends the
matter to the House, where the votes shall be
taken by states. The representation from each
state having one vote. Republicans currently
control 26 state delegations. President Trump
is reelected there as well. Step five, one last
piece, assuming the Electoral Count Act process
is followed and upon getting the objections to the
Arizona slates, the two houses break into separate
chambers, we should not allow that the electoral
count act constraint on debate to control.
That would mean that a prior legislature was
determining the rules of the present. One,
a constitutional no no. So someone, Ted Cruz, Rand
Paul should demand normal rules, which includes
the filibuster. That creates a stalemate. And it
would give the state legislatures more time to
weigh in to formally support the alternate slate
of electors if they haven't already done so.
And finally, step six. The main thing here is that
pens should do this without asking for permission,
either from a vote of the joint session or from
the court. Let the other side challenge his
actions in court. What? Sorry. And the Zoome
just went crazy. Let me get resumed in here.
Number six, let the other side challenge his
actions in court, where tribe who conceded in 2001
the president of the Senate might be in charge of
counting the votes and others who would press a
lawsuit that these are nonjusticiable, justifiable
political questions thrown back at them. OK,
step six is like so far out there that it's not
even even as relevant, although this is completely
absurd and ludicrous. Imagine if Donald Trump had
had someone as his vice president, willing to try,
like pense just said, I'm not even going to I'm
not even going to try because I can't do it.
I still believe it would not have succeeded, but
it would have caused a hell of a lot of chaos
in the process. And then, you know, I know these
terms are hyperbolic. The terms I'm about to use,
if they had pulled off, what would have been a
coup? Could it have launched a civil war of sorts,
like what would actually happen if this
had been attempted? And then they would
have used that to say, look at how violent the
left is, an absolutely insane six step plan.
I guess it feels weird to say this, but I guess
in some way we should be glad it was pense and
not someone even crazier like Marge VPI. Marjorie
Taylor Green almost certainly tries this VPE. Matt
Gates probably tries this. It still fails, but it
might cause insane chaos and violence in so doing.